welcome to the reason stream I'm Zach
Weissmuller joined by my colleague Liz
Wolfe hey Liz hey thanks for having me
Zach
today we're going to talk about the
higher ed Wars uh specifically the
ongoing conflict over diversity equity
and inclusion standards or what critics
tend to term wokeness on the college
campus we've seen this play out in
Florida where I'm coming to you from and
in in in the form of an expansive law
known as the stop woke act that Outlaws
professors from teaching several
prohibited Concepts around racial
identity it's also playing out in my
former State of California where the
community college system has attempted
to mandate the teaching of many of these
very same Concepts that leaves us in
that situation all too familiar to many
Libertarians where everything not
forbidden must be compelled
but there's an organization that's
fighting against both California and
Florida on this front and it's known as
fire the foundation for individual
rights and expression formerly known as
the foundation for individual rights in
education
a uh rebranding that we'll talk about a
bit more later
so I'm happy to Welcome to the stream
Jesse Appleby an attorney with fire who
is part of a lawsuit called Paul's Guard
versus Christian that alleges the
California Community College's Dei
standards are both unlawfully compelling
speech and restricting speech Jesse
thank you for joining us today
thanks for having me
we also are hoping we're going to be
joined by a plaintiff in that suit Bill
blanken he's running a little bit behind
but he may join us later he's a
chemistry professor at Reedley College
in California but for now let's Jump
Right In with a look at the big picture
here here's the lawsuit Paul's Guard
versus uh so Paul's guard is one of the
professors there's a whole list of
professors that who are the plaintiffs
and then on the other side of the Ledger
we've got a list of various California
Community College
uh officials
how did this case against California's
community college system come about in
the first place Jesse
well last year
um in probably March 2022
the community college system released a
draft regulation that would mandate the
teaching and
kind of embraced by professors of these
Dei standards and at the time
um fire and other organizations
submitted public comments objecting
strongly to the content of the
regulations and
um
the California community college system
ignored those uh comments and those
objections to the regulations and ended
up approving them
in May 2022 and then officially filed
them with the Secretary of State this
spring
um but the regulations also came about
as part of a longer term project that
started in 2019 by the state Chancellor
of the community college system uh
that was kind of a Dei push in to every
part of the system how can we kind of
overhaul the system to
Embrace Dei
so why is this happening at the
community college level that's the thing
that I'm I'm very curious about is there
a similar thing happening with the
university system in California like why
is this happening there and is this by
and large supported by students or is
this actually pretty top down
there are there is definitely
um
movement with Dei in the University
system itself it's because it's a
different system
it's not identical to what's happening
within the community college system
um
we get a lot of reports from
the California state universities
um about the use of Dei statements in
hiring in even using them as kind of a
threshold in hiring so that you have to
pass Dei the Dei statement review before
you get to the
review of your actual resume and career
and everything
um so there are definitely a push for
Dei at the University system but it's
just completely separate from the
community college system
um why it's happening at the community
college level
I don't know I mean we we're seeing it
everywhere we're seeing it in
universities and community colleges
everywhere so I
my best guess there would just be
different leadership in different
systems choose to implement it
differently
yeah that makes sense but it seems like
it's a pretty top-down imposition not
something that's bottom-up led by
students like this is really you know
has to do with hiring uh and we're
reading the lawsuit and it has a lot to
do with tenure reviews and whether or
not professors can qualify for that is
that correct yes this regulation itself
is buried top down it comes from the
state Chancellor and the State Board of
Governors and there it's imposed on the
um
100 plus Community College districts and
or maybe 70 some districts and 100 some
colleges within the system they teach
nearly 2 million students it's imposed
by the state on all of those I mean do
you have a sense as to is the community
college system in California
more centralized in that way than the UC
system I mean I know that you know
independent colleges within the UC
system I assume would have a lot of
leeway and flexibility based on what
their you know board believes is right
for the university is it less so that
for community colleges or do you know
the answer to that
I I'm probably not well informed enough
on the structure of the USB system at
the University level to uh give any kind
of real answer on that um I just don't
know how similar or different it is yeah
that's fair enough let's dig into the
introduction to the complaint uh which
says that among other things Dei the the
deia rules we've got to add a on there I
believe for accessibility uh mandates
Viewpoint Conformity compelled
professors to teach and preach the
state's perspective on deia impose a
prior restraint on the sharing of
contrary views and subject professors to
an array of overbroad vague and
arbitrary requirements so let's take
some of those one by one the first one
is this idea of compelled speech which
is your third cause of action listed
here you say that it's unconstitutional
compelled speech that violates the First
Amendment could you just explain the
meaning of your allegation there
sure compelled speech is
um it's when the government tells you
what you have to say uh it's when the
government says
we require all faculty to
say a particular thing about Dei
um most First Amendment
um issues that people think of is the
government trying to shut people up this
is just the opposite the government
trying to make people who want to maybe
stay quiet
speak
and speak the government's message
is there legal precedent for compelled
speech like what what sort of cases have
there been in the past that deal with
this issue of compelled speech because
when people think of First Amendment
they they tend to think of you know the
government stopping you from saying
something not in a way forcing you to
say something
yeah well actually uh in the
California was the kind of original home
of some of the uh First cases in this
area which were the Loyalty oath cases
of the 50s
um when the UC system required faculty
to
essentially pledge allegiance and
confirm that they were not communists uh
that would be kind of an instance of
compelled speech requiring a loyalty
oath of some sort requiring
um
kind of like a DEA Dei statement in
hiring now it's requiring you to confirm
that you believe something and
um in order to hold a job with the
government uh so those were some of the
first cases since then uh there have
been
all sorts of compelled speech cases uh
some have been with um
wow I'm blanking on my example but uh
yes we have seen them in universities
where you can't tell professors to
essentially
speak or teach a particular Viewpoint
hmm right and I'd like to also right now
we're going to add Bill blank into the
stream he's popped in uh bill is as I
mentioned at the top of the show a
chemistry professor at Reedley College
and one of the plaintiffs in this case
Bill welcome to the reason stream
hi how you doing
good we were just talking about the
concept of compelled speech that as it's
laid out in this case as a professor who
is party to the case do you feel that
these Dei standards are compelling you
to express ideas that you don't agree
with and if so in what way
uh definitely and I think it's beyond
even what I agree with personally or not
it's it's a waste of classroom time
we have a limited amount of time that we
need to get through a lot of material
every class period whether it's lecture
in the lab
and
I think in The Sciences is it's
particularly inappropriate because
um
you know there's a quote that's
attributed to me what is the Dei
anti-racist perspective on the atomic
mass of of boron and and that really
lays it out because
um
science Should Have No Agenda other than
you know Relentless pursuit of the truth
and wherever that leads and with Dei
we're expected to
search out racism within you know
science curriculum Etc and it's just not
there
so
um yeah it really interferes it's going
to interfere with um with classroom
instruction as well as laboratory work
yeah I'm really curious here what
exactly do they expect you to do in
order to infuse your teaching with Dei
like I'm very curious like do you have
colleagues in The Sciences who are on
board with this and like how do they
anticipate doing this it seems
contrary to my understanding of what one
typically learns in a chemistry class
well I honestly think Liz that
um my colleagues many of them are just
going to go along and and I'm just going
to be very Frank here give lip service
and
um
they'll in the in the evaluation process
that's where this really comes down as a
tenured faculty member all of my
colleagues are also tenured
um
when we get evaluated we have a
self-evaluation and there's also
classroom observation from our Dean and
a faculty peer and
the self-evaluation is where there's a
lot of questions about you know what are
we going to be doing or what have we
done
um to promote anti-racism and Dei
a ideologies which is really what it is
it's an ideology and so
um I think many of them in fact I've
actually now that I think about it have
been told recently since the lawsuit was
filed that they appreciate what we're
doing because
you know they're they're kind of too
afraid to stick their neck out and
they're just going to go along and give
lip service to you know we do this this
and this but I think some of them are
not aware that if they say that they
treat all students the same that's
considered a racist statement and and
thought process by the people who have
put together
um the Dei a you know I'll call
standards here in California it's not
enough to say I treat all this all my
students the same
that's not enough that's not going far
enough so
um I don't know there's only four of us
total where I teach and I haven't had a
lot of contact since the lawsuit was
filed with uh my colleagues at the other
sister campuses
but um I'm sure that there are some in
fact you know now now that my memory got
jogged again I know that there are
faculty who essentially have removed all
reference
to any scientist or you know
physicist
who happens to be white and and
I think that is just
not helpful to the discipline let's put
it that way are there like specific
scientists like so so I would imagine
there are some very famous scientists
who have thus been removed from
curriculum do you have any examples of
like what would happen if you cleansed
all the white people from the history of
your study like like who who would be a
race who would students no longer learn
about
well what I'm what I have just recently
taught we always learn at the beginning
of the semester you know where does the
principle of the atom come from where
does the who discovered the electrons so
to speak yeah and scientists like
Rutherford and and so many others even
even you know Democritus we bring him up
because
um of the Greeks view that you know
matter was
um the idea of being able to split
matter into smaller and smaller pieces
and it's people like that would would
get completely cleansed and so you would
just learn about an experiment per se
and there would be no name attached to
well who did that work
and so that's that's kind of how it
plays out it just becomes you know very
sterile but I will say this now that I
again think about this there are there
are laws
um what I call law we call them laws uh
the gas laws in particular and then
there's named after certain scientists
what are we gonna we're gonna rename
those and then the Kelvin temperature
scale okay which is the scale used in in
science
is named after Lord Kelvin he happens to
be white what are we going to do rename
that call it something else so that's
that's kind of really really how this
plays out
and I think it's it's been set up I'm
gonna you know
give my opinion now but I think it's
been set up that way in some sense on
purpose so that whatever somebody does
It's never enough I think with the right
administrator and the right HR they can
say it's not enough you need to go
further
what is the reaction been of some of
your colleagues I I know you mentioned
that kind of communication with
Administration has been cut off but you
know you are at a college in California
I assume the faculty leans pretty
Progressive and might be uncomfortable
with the stance you're taking here how
has that manifested in terms of just
day-to-day interactions on campus
uh my particular campus is
um
I would say it's a mixed bag as far as
people's ideologies
um and beliefs it's it's not your
I hesitate to even say it but it's not
your typical what you would perceive as
a California college campus
and the The Faculty who have approached
me have been completely supportive of
what what we're doing and
uh as far as if a faculty member on the
campus does not support what I'm doing
nobody has said anything to me
so
um so that that plays into the idea that
we were talking about the beginning that
this is much more of a top-down
imposition rather than something that
people at least on your campus are
clamoring for on mass
um you know I you mentioned the the
performance evaluations that I'm going
to pull up this slide from the lawsuit
uh which says that the evaluation of
employee performance including 10-year
reviews that requires requires
demonstrated or progress toward
Proficiency in the locally developed Dei
competencies so this is the mechanism
for enforcement is I guess you go to
your annual review and that is one of
the metrics your judge judged upon and
it seems like even even tenure is in in
play here so uh what is it that
how is it that you expect
this to play out once let's say that
this law were to remain in effect or
this regulation were to remain in effect
how would that play out come annual
review time what how would the way that
your performance is evaluated do you
think would be different than it has
been in the past
uh yeah that's a good question
um let me go back to something you said
at the beginning this definitely is top
down I don't know a single faculty
member that
um
in in all the discussions in in the
entire 15 plus years I've been where I'm
at that at read the college that that
wants this in terms of auras as you said
clamoring for this I don't know a single
faculty member that
um personally now I'm I'm sure there are
progressives on the campus that
um when what happened in 2020 I know
they went all in
um
but I have not had a single discussion
with anybody
in The Sciences at least that
where I'm at that wants that wants this
that is asking for this this is 100 top
down that is that is a great
characterization now as far as my
performance evaluation well again we we
call it an evaluation
and now that I'm since I'm tenured
it's every three years now this this
affects me but it really is going to
affect new hires they're evaluated every
year
and
I want to make everybody aware of
something else that's happening right
now and that is they have changed and
what I mean by they is it's a community
college system of California and our
camp our district has made it very clear
that we are to change hiring practices
and and who gets interviews and who
ultimately gets hired
um it has been 100 influenced by the the
deia ideology
and so that is happening right now as
well so back to my evaluation
I'm supposed to be evaluated next spring
and it's a look back it is what am I
doing this semester what did I do
meaning fall what did I do the previous
two years and now that they have this
new these these new questions in the
rubric what did I do to you know forward
anti-racist principles and what did I do
to basically forward deia principles I
don't know the exact question off the
top of my head but that's that's the the
Crux of it is that they're going to look
back and as far as as my tenure at risk
I to be very Frank I don't know why it
wouldn't be because it all depends on
who is going to be evaluating
my responses to those questions
um what I anticipate now I'm just giving
my opinion I don't have any
um proof of this I haven't received some
document that said that this is what's
going to happen but just in my
experience in how things typically go
what I'm anticipating is that if we give
an answer I give an answer that they
don't find appropriate there's
discussion about this and then HR will
say well why don't you undergo a little
bit of additional bias training why
don't you undergo some training to
actually show you how to be an
anti-racist bill that's what I would
anticipate happening and it's to me it's
a struggle session we're gonna have to
have I'm going to have a little struggle
session
and um
perhaps you know again I'm just giving
my opinion this may be
seeming bike from left field but
um that's how this kind of stuff goes is
that well you're gonna you're gonna go
to training until your mind is right the
thing that's so interesting about this
to me is that it's not as if there is a
clear actionable thing that a specific
faculty member has done wrong using a
mean nasty racial slur toward a student
that's not what's happening it is rather
this almost like Obama era traditionally
liberal sort of like yeah we'll treat
everybody the same as best we can that's
the aspiration it's almost like that
thing that we by and large kind of all
agreed was a good thing you know treat
people equally as best you can you know
try to be you know somewhat colorblind I
mean they're all students in a classroom
you want to be accommodating and
respectful of students as best you can
given their diverse needs but by and
large you want to treat people equally
and like that's really the thing that's
under Fire in today's new Dia regime
um so that's the thing that's just kind
of stunning to me about all of this is
like there's like an absence of
instigating awful incident it is rather
that things have been chugging along I
guess at a pace and in a way that many
of the deia
administrators in the DIA industry writ
large is not comfortable with and does
not want they want to stamp out
um I guess this old way of thinking
about things which at least from my view
is very aligned with Enlightenment
thinking this idea of like it is
important for each person's dignity to
be respected uh and to you know for
people to be judged on their character
and on their Merit
and we're going to get into in just a
second all of the what exactly it is
that is being put forth what these
concepts are that they want you to
espouse in the classroom so that I mean
at this point I think people know a lot
of this stuff because we you know in
every sector of life you're kind of like
you're exposed to it but it's still
useful to look at the exact Concepts uh
we're gonna go through that but I before
we do I wanted to ask Jesse one last
question which is uh another aspect of
the lawsuit is that you you say there's
the compelled speech but then you say
that they're all they also tell faculty
what they are not allowed to say faculty
are warned not to quote weaponize
academic freedom and academic Integrity
as tools to impede Equity or inflict
curricular trauma on our students so the
language of like physical violence being
invoked here but could you just lay that
out from a legal perspective how is how
are these regulations not only
compelling speech but you're alleging
impeding speech infringing on and saying
what you are not allowed to say
yeah that's
what's interesting about these
particular Dei rules uh because they so
bake in kind of a full-throated ideology
and fairly explicitly
um say use terms and say this is the
kind of world view we expect you to
adopt
um they both expect faculty members to
espouse that worldview but they also
warn against
um
preaching a different world view because
of the harm that it'll do to
um
marginalized students or
different identity groups
um it's both it's kind of flip sides of
the same coin uh you need to embrace one
world view which means you cannot
embrace
a contrary worldview
that makes sense so you're you're
they're saying you you should say this
script more or less and not not that
script uh so that's the flip size of the
coin and it's laid out in this well hold
on I was just gonna say what's
interesting to me about that excerpt
though is the like verbiage of
weaponizing academic freedom I mean in a
sense this is attempting to
um condemn the you know journalists or
lawyers or people who are just making
the full-throated free speech on
principle argument this idea of
weaponizing academic freedom no I don't
think anybody sitting here is interested
in weaponizing academic freedom we
believe in academic freedom and are
interested in preserving that principle
that we hold dear that we believe to be
absolutely essential to our ability to
engage in free inquiry um but even them
just throwing that word weaponized at
the beginning beginning of it like to
what degree does that then make it so
you as a lawyer representing this case
you're not supposed to be doing that and
you're not so you're certainly if you're
a faculty member not supposed to be
hiring lawyers to make that case I
really get concerned when I see words
like weaponized academic freedom because
to me Bill Bill are you weaponizing
academic freedom
you know I wanted to chime in I've had
conversations with administrators at a
local another local College
um where I have colleagues and or I
should say friends that teach and they
don't subscribe to the idea of academic
freedom in the way that all four of us
understand it to be and they use
language like the true definition of
academic freedom and part of the problem
is that these administrators they're a
vice president level administrators and
Dean level positions they've never been
faculty they've literally never been
faculty and they get hired for reasons
um I could only guess at
but
that is part of the problem right there
and then you you so that you so you have
this ideologically driven person that's
evaluating faculty using language like
the true definition of academic freedom
words mean things and ideas matter
and so
um they it's this new speak that is just
so pervasive I don't weaponize academic
freedom the idea of academic freedom is
a long-standing tradition in higher
education that allows us to present
ideas which May challenge our students
current belief about whatever now
um you know we don't have too much of
that per se in chemistry it's just hard
facts and we're learning about how atoms
and molecules work but as it relates to
something like say you know man-made
climate change or that's a belief and so
um things of that nature as a faculty
member I need to have the right this is
a long-standing tradition and right to
bring up certain ideas
and no we're not weaponizing academic
freedom we don't I don't know of a
single incident where a faculty member
has you know done something to a person
of color you know who was the and the
faculty member was white so we grade
everybody the same
and true and to say that is now an
offense in and of itself
yeah sorry I was just going to say
traditionally you know that that is
ostensibly the point of tenure so the
the idea that they're undermining tenure
to advance this is particularly alarming
to me even though you know we can have a
larger debate if we want to about you
know what whether 10 years the right
mechanism or not for Academia but I mean
that that this is clearly the kind of
ultimate like this is the purpose of it
uh and uh for for that to be now thrown
into question is I don't know that's
particularly concerning to me I want to
bring up this document which you've
entered into evidence Jesse Dei in
curriculum model principles and
practices this was put out by the
California community colleges and really
lays out Point by Point what it is they
expect to see in the classroom could you
before we dive into the documents
details could you tell us what is the
import of this
well this is one of several documents
that
that the State Community College system
uh issued to inform the individual
districts and colleges
um how to apply the new Dei rules and
this document in particular is this is
what we want to see when you are
applying Dei in the classroom this is
how you incorporate it into your
curriculum this is these are the kind of
practices you should use and not use or
the types of language you should use and
not use uh to be compliant with the
state's definition of Dei
so this will be a sort of reference for
you know if this system is implemented
where professors are evaluated where
this is incorporated into their
evaluations you'll be like this is the
reference document are you aligning with
what is laid out here it's one of
several sources that that they're going
to be referencing that's correct
yes
and looking inside of it this is the
kind of big picture Vision they lay out
that one you develop and Implement a
pedagogy or curriculum that promotes a
race conscious and intersectional lens
and equip students to engage with the
world as Scholars and citizens develops
and implements a pedagogy that Fosters
an anti-racive or anti-racist and
inclusive environment for a minoritized
students
um demonstrates an ability to teach
culturally affirming pedagogy
what is your reaction to that bill as
someone who would be affected by these
new standards
well again it's it's uh it's this this
relative terminology is kind of the way
I look at it
um anti-racism anti-racist
um intersectionality
um
interests
yeah yeah you you ask five different
people and they're gonna have five
different definitions
and I don't know how
um to work in the anti-racist ideology
to Boyle's Law
I'm sorry that Boyle was a white
scientist you know physicist 200 plus
years ago or something along those lines
but
um it it really becomes I think it's
Preposterous because
the periodic table of the elements is
what I'm charged with teaching students
about and explaining how that was
constructed etc etc and how it works and
um
I think it's relative in the way they're
going to
evaluate me and it's not objective
and
I have real concerns about my future in
Academia as do you know the other people
who have enjoined in the lawsuit as well
um because
administrators
you know sometimes
you know I I would say I'm trying to
figure out the most polite way to say
this they they can bear grudges and so
um
I think that that evaluation language
can be interpreted so many different
ways well you're not going far enough
yeah I recognize that you did X Y and Z
but you didn't go far enough you could
have went further
so that's that's kind of how this I
think I'm anticipating this working I
just want to add that there's a certain
hilarity like you know say we like put
on our little Marxist hats for a second
here there's a certain hilarity to the
fact that it's administrators who are
frequently paid you know a pretty penny
uh in the college environment as well as
some of the Dei Consultants where now
there's like a pretty thriving industry
a lot of these di consulting firms make
Bank
um and there's a little bit of
absurdity to these very highly paid
professionals being the sort of
enforcers of this
um you know and implementing a very
top-down thing which I would imagine
many students at California community
colleges do not come from the most you
know economically privileged backgrounds
in the entire world and or are working
really hard to put themselves through
school and to attempt to you know work
their way up in the world and so I just
think that there's also something kind
of fascinating about that of like who
are the people doing the enforcement of
this
um if they actually care about you know
lifting the people who are the absolute
most oppressed there's a certain uh
absurdity to the fact that many of them
I think are probably paid an awful lot
of money very handsomely to do this type
of thing
um
so I want to add to that there's uh
there's a bit of a tempest happening in
the uh
um
not the community college system but the
state college system so in California
you have the UCS University of
California you have the Cal State and
then you have the community college
system so in the Cal State right now
they are negotiating
and I think it's system-wide with
faculty unions and administration is
playing Hardball they they want to give
minimal raise but contrast that to
administrators whose raises have far
outpaced
faculty and inflation so to speak and
you have you have administrators in the
California State University system so
that would be you know places like Cal
State LA
Cal State Fresno Cal State Fullerton Etc
you have administrators that are making
you know just under a million dollars
you know college presidents and then you
you it just kind of goes down from there
they get they get housing allowances
there are people within the Cal State
system who get a housing allowance and
mileage which is greater than what
professors monthly pay is and so I think
you point out something that's really
good that these administrators who wear
this is where this is all coming from
um and you have faculty you know that
are definitely Marxist
um as well but you have these the
administrators who are really pushing
this
making tremendous amounts of money far
more than they would ever make in the
private sector
and I think you point out something that
just is really remarkable it's it's
hypocrisy it's our you know
um there's a lot of different adjectives
we could probably come up with to
describe this but
um
yeah it's it's exactly that you have
administrators making huge amounts of
money
compared to faculty and they're the ones
decrying
you know white privilege and everything
else
yeah there's uh there's a a real
industry that has popped up uh around
this uh both at the higher ed level but
also in the corporate level and a little
bit we're we're going to play a clip
from one of the kind of original
creators of that industry describing how
that kicked off and I think your your
point is is well made Liz that and Bill
that yes there's this administrative
bloat uh it actually pervades all
education not just higher ed like if you
look at the amount of money that has
gone into the education system uh an
alarming percentage of that has gone to
administrative staff and you you can see
the lines where their their growth has
gone up and you know kind of teacher pay
has stayed flat so that there yeah
there's a real interesting economic
Dynamic there do I want to dive back
into the concepts for a second before we
get uh into like the the industry that
has popped up around this that this is
from that same document where you've got
uh side to side traditional educational
practice versus Equity principle so this
is a kind of do's and don'ts in this new
classroom setup and if we zoom in on it
the traditional education practice would
be classroom experiences or assignments
and assessments that are built from an
individualist perspective that's the
don't the the new way to do it the
equity principle is to shift to a
collectivism perspective to engage
authentic lived experiences and relate
to students cultural norms
what are you going to do Bill to shift
from the individualist perspective to
the collectivism perspective in your
Chemistry classes in this semester
nothing I'm not going to do it
fair enough
I'm
I'm just not going to comply
um I'm going to teach chemistry the way
I always have I'm going to teach
chemistry in the way that is the most
logical way to get the information and
the skill set into my students
I teach students I teach freshman level
chemistry for science majors and these
are people who want to go to medical
school and they want to go to pharmacy
school and I also teach introchem
for students that want to become nurses
and other Allied health professionals
and their skills that they need to bring
from my classroom such as dosage
calculation
um that they need to carry on if they
don't get anywhere else and particularly
in the in the the
students that want to go to nursing
school
and one of the things about some a
discipline like chemistry is
as well as math and physics is that it's
one of the best places to learn to think
critically and logically and problem
solve
and that's what I'm concerned about I'm
not concerned about collectivism
um
and
I do evaluate my students on an
individual basis and so if anything I
I'm I am
strongly individualistic because
my students get the grades that come
from their own personal work
you know so are we
are we to collectivize grades so
everybody you know gets a c now or a c
minus
so yeah that's the kind of confusing
thing about it I I know one aspect of
the lawsuit too is about vagueness
because if I were in this position
reading some of this would be really
confusing I wouldn't even quite
understand what the actionable like
instruction is because of the way that
the language is just the the the kind of
Flowery or you know abstract language uh
they did helpfully provide a glossary
which I've pulled up here and uh one of
the terms that I know uh lit caught
Liz's interest is uh watering up uh
could you uh share with us Liz what
watering up is and I mean
this is the problem with so much of this
like I just literally don't know what
this means I am a journalist I spend all
day writing words and parsing their
meaning and this is not super clear to
me
um I mean read a little bit of it our
listening audience watering up is
apparently you know instructional
practices with the science of learning
that we can Apprentice students to be
active agents in their own learning
instead of watering them down with
compliance oriented deficit views this
process requires students to build and
braid together multiple neural
relational and experiential processes to
produce their own unique learning
acceleration process I'm sorry this
feels like if you fed chat GPT HR
buzzwords it's not clear to me how a
professor is actually supposed to
implement this or how this is a useful I
mean the thing that I just keep coming
back to because ever since becoming a
mom I've been pretty interested in a lot
of the stuff related to phonics
education and the crisis related to how
children have been taught how to read in
many public schools in this country
which is obviously at a different level
than the level that we're talking about
but I just keep coming back to this
question of like wait a second at many
schools across the country there's this
huge problem which is that like there
isn't enough instructional time or
suitable enough instruction in the first
place to get kids to the level that they
need to be at and then you also look at
College classroom environments and it's
not clear to me why we ought to be
trying to get instructors to be spending
more time on these very vague
wishy-washy Concepts versus actually
ensuring that kids and young adults
learn the things that they need to be
learning they need to learn how to read
or like what you're talking about
um you know they they need to be
figuring out how to uh you know the
basics of dosage like one of the things
that I just keep coming back to is
when we Orient ourselves more toward
these things
are we setting people up to fail because
we're actually I mean it comes at a cost
and what's the cost actually useful
instructional time
do you have an app on that bill
that's exactly right it takes away we
have a limited amount of time
and we have a tremendous amount of
material that we have to go over and
skills that they have to learn
and
I think what you said too at the
beginning was right that it is
there's multiple definitions of these
words this administrator or this
Advocate or
um
I want to say you know I think Advocate
maybe we're grifter maybe a good word
um
they have a definition of this word and
somebody else has a different definition
of the word well how am I going to be
objectively evaluated in my faculty
evaluation if I've got these multiple
definitions of the word that I'm looking
at whose do I go with
yeah I it also to be it strikes me as a
little insulting to people's time I
recall I came from a more privileged
background but I still you know was
working as I made my way through college
and my time was really scarce and if I
had been forced to in my view waste more
time on these types of things versus
actually getting useful instruction that
would have been really frustrating to me
I would imagine most community college
students in the California system feel
much the same way and in a sense this is
very disrespectful to people who might
be working a few jobs to pay their way
through college
um to then force them to spend time on
things that are perhaps pretty unrelated
to them actually securing the type of
success that they they hope to get later
on Zach could you also take us to the
um collectivism individualism
definitions
this is the one that uh yeah this is the
one that jumped out to me uh their
definitions from the glossary of
collectivism was an individual sense of
connection to and responsibility for
members of their group community so
sounds sounds very warm and fuzzy
individualism the valuing of the
individual over the value of groups or
society as a whole so I mean this is an
incredibly by these are both incredibly
biased definitions clearly written by
someone more sympathetic to collectivism
and and look you you can be a
collectivist I think history would show
it's the wrong way to think about human
nature but using the state to impose
that kind of Orthodoxy on academics
people who are supposed to be
intellectuals are are free thinkers is
incredibly disturbing to me and you know
fire as the foundation for individual
rights and expressions I've got to
assume there's some people that are made
uncomfortable by this as well Jesse like
what is just your reaction as someone
who is trying to stand up for individual
rights so that seeing that sort of thing
being imposed
well
I I would say as a defender of
individual rights that also includes uh
defending the individual rights of
people who want to uh
it promote collectivism
as well as individualism so I I think we
would object to
compelling anyone to embrace any
particular point of view uh whether that
be individualism or collectivism and in
both cases we would defend the person
who's
individual rights were being
um
violated
but yes as an organization we exist to
specifically to defend the rights of
individuals
I think this is uh the really delightful
thing that fire does I just appreciate I
mean I think we'll talk about it in a
little bit in a few minutes here but we
really are so
um
kind of delighted by the fact that like
we can criticize so much of this and the
um you know the compelled speech here
and fire is doing such a good job of
representing these California professors
but then you also look at some of the
things happening in Florida related to
the the stopwoke act and um the sort of
Chris Ruffo uh one-man mission to create
a different sort of viewpoint Conformity
um at many schools in that state and I
really appreciate and I think we as as
Libertarians at reason also kind of
straddle that very very tight we we walk
that tightrope of like no don't mandate
that thing over there but then also even
the thing that I like you shouldn't be
mandating
um any sort of viewpoint conformity in
that realm either it's really really
important that individuals have full
ability to legitimately go out into the
world and decide what they believe and
authentically hold and articulate those
beliefs for themselves as opposed to
having any institution impose things top
down and I mean without this we don't
have through academic freedom we don't
have the ability for people to really
engage in robust discussion and come to
you know take their half truths and and
you know have them blossom in like a
very JS Mill type way
yep and I want to get to we're going to
uh spend the last part of this
conversation talking a little bit about
the stop woke act which is kind of the
flip side of what's going on in
California while we still have uh bill
here with us because I know he has to
jump off uh around uh 12 30.
um I want to uh talk about what we
touched on earlier which was the sort of
Industry that has come up around this
the where some of these Concepts uh have
come from I'm bringing up a slide from
the website based on the website of uh
Tama Okun who is a activist and one of
the corporate Consultants who's
responsible for a lot of these Concepts
that we see in that glossary we just
went through she runs a website called
dismantlingracism.org you can see some
of the uh Concepts that are uh
problematically associated with white
supremacy here perfectionism
individualism objectivity sense of
urgency defensiveness
she was interviewed earlier this year by
Ryan Grimm of the The Intercept uh on a
podcast where she had some interesting
things to say about the origins of her
workbook that was later used as the
basis for a lot of both corporate and
academic Dei work I wants to take a
listen to that clip uh and get your
reaction to what she's saying so
here's Tim Oakley
I went to some kind of meeting and I
don't remember any details of the
meeting but I went to a meeting and it
was a very frustrating and horrible
meeting and I came home and I sat in
front of the computer and the article
literally came through me onto the
computer it was not researched it was
not I didn't sit down and
and deliberate it just came through me
and I've never had that experience with
my writing before since and someone
somewhere along the line once the
internet became more active just took
the workbook and posted pieces of it on
the internet so you hadn't even posted
it no I never posted it I never once
posted it I never ever expected it to be
used certainly out of context of the
whole piece so then it just started
circulating and
um it kind of started to have a life of
its own and then when George Floyd was
murdered it really started to have a
life of its own and started having a
whole lot of views it is becoming a Dei
industrial complex
you know with all the problems that that
brings but I kind of wonder what's the
alternative are we not to address it at
all I mean if we can't address it right
do we not address it you know this is
this is 400 years in the making the more
more things people are trying the better
the more of us in in the
in the fight the better uh the more
wisdom and ways of doing things people
bring the better and along the way yeah
it's going to be messy and people are
going to go after each other and
um you know part of part of the reason
for for my being here today is just to
say to those people who are misusing my
work please stop just don't just don't
you know it's not it's not meant to to
be used to Target people that's not what
it's meant for it's meant to bring
people together to talk about how we're
getting in our own way and what we can
do differently
so what I hear there is that the the
idea
for her workbook her her influential
workbook kind of came to her
spontaneously almost like you know uh it
came down it was handed down to her and
flowed out uh even two tablets on the
Mountaintop and but but she said she's
since she's since refined it and uh now
she acknowledges that there's been this
uh you know grow this profitable Dei
industry and people misuse these
Concepts sometimes but it's a messy
process and it it's good that people are
are at least trying here
um I guess I'll start I'll I'll get Bill
to react to the second but first Jesse I
I want to get your thoughts on
the way she characterizes uh the way Dei
is is implemented in the real world and
where you know we draw the line between
this kind of experimentation she's
talking about and something that crosses
the line into illegality
yeah that's kind of been the
um
the tough challenge when we're looking
at all of these Dei uh policies at
different places is they
um
a lot of them are quite broadly written
and so the question does arise
um how much is this compelling anything
is it just a suggestion where is it
guidance and where is it used against
people to judge their say performance
and or uh judge their uh
their Merit to being hired uh that that
has been the very
tough Challenge and I think what we've
seen is that
even the broadly written ones often are
more compulsory in practice than you
might assume just from the text of the
policy uh
it gives those administrating the
program kind of the
discretion uh to apply it as they see
wish at or as they wish and that often
means they will apply it in an arbitrary
discriminatory manner but it does become
at least for some uh definitely more
compulsory in practice than you would
guess from the text on the page
and Bill uh did you have any reaction to
just kind of the I guess admission there
or concession that this has become a
sort of industry and there's a whole
bureaucracy attached to it but perhaps
that's in a way a good thing because
this is the way we progress as a society
is you you need these structures to
emerge
connection could you repeat your
question
oh sure yeah I you know I I I'm not sure
if you heard any of that the clip that
we just played earlier
um but I was just asking for your
reaction to the idea that um yes there
is a Dei bureaucracy but maybe that is a
good and necessary thing
well I I want to take a step back first
and say I can categorically without
reservations say there are no racist
faculty at my college and my suspicion
is
for all intents and purposes
there are no racist faculty in my entire
School District at least you know white
racists let's put it that way
and so I think the whole premise of her
entire work is false so it's built upon
a lie to begin with
but having said that this notion that
she has or this this request that she
has that people stop using it to go
after faculty to put it that way
um I think that's
I'm going to be very Frank here that's
awfully convenient of her to say that
but that's the net effect is is what
it's going to be used as it's going to
be used as a cudgel
against
faculty and and
even probably administrators who would
resist it as well
who don't support her
or don't support the deia philosophy
so and as far as
it being necessary to have these in
place no it's it's not necessary again
her her entire work is built on on a lie
the the thing that's interesting to me
and I'm curious about your thought here
bill right before you I know you have to
leave really soon but is like I'm
curious about I wish the DIA
um imposers the people who are imposing
it on faculty I wish they would sort of
sketch out what culturally affirming
classroom practices do in fact look like
because one thing that keeps jumping
into my mind as we consider Tima okan
and what she's talking about here is
like doesn't this very easily go Veer
into the territory of tokenizing
students right like aren't there some
students who don't want the hijab that
they're wearing to be pointed out
um and want to be able to be treated
like any other person in the classroom
or it would feel odd if somebody was
talking about for example you know in a
legal class the um Trump Rico Georgia
case and you know decided to bring the
rappers in Atlanta who were also um who
are also facing Rico charges like young
thug into the mix and you know
specifically was trying to be culturally
affirming of a black student's identity
but in doing so assumed that a black
student follows Young Thug when in fact
they might not follow that rapper like
I'm very curious about it it feels like
it can kind of go both ways where a
culturally affirming classroom practice
could make somebody feel more welcome
but also I could very easily see a
situation where the exact same type of
thing ends up making somebody feel very
stereotyped or very singled out do you
have any thoughts on that tension and
how that would work in a classroom
environment bill
yeah so first of all you know I I
wouldn't say I've I've pulled my
students precisely do you support Dei a
ideology and principles I haven't done
that
uh per se but I've nibbled around the
edges and I'm comfortable saying that
the vast majority of my students do not
support this because let's it really
occurred to me recently when I was
thinking about our lawsuit that what
this what this deia ideology does is it
effectively strips the individual
identity away from my students it it
turns them from being an individual to
being
part of a group part of a collective and
I can safely say that again 90 plus
percent of my students would not like
that they are individuals and they want
to be treated with their own individual
identity not part of a whole and that's
what this does it it's going to demand
that we treat all students
I hate this term students of color
as part of groups
and the vast majority of my students are
not white I maybe have
in a class of 20 one or two white
students the rest are not white
and and they don't want to be treated as
a group they are all different and
that's what they want
I want to close out the conversation
here with a site uh with um a case that
you cite in your lawsuit called Purnell
versus Florida Board of Governors of
State University system uh where you say
you quote from that the judge's ruling
there saying that it's not acceptable to
impose
uh the state to impose its own Orthodoxy
a Viewpoint about the content allowed
within University classrooms and of
course the case that we're talking about
here is one that par that fire is also
party two against uh the state of
Florida's uh law that has become known
as the stop woke act the individual
rights and Education Act I produced a
short documentary about that issue and
I'm going to play a quick clip from it
where Purnell the named plaintiff in the
case Professor Purnell uh speaks out
about his feelings about the stop woke
act and how it would affect what he's
doing in the classroom so that we can
see the flip side of that conversation
Purnell a law professor at Florida a m
University or FAMU and historically
black college is a plaintiff in the
aclu's case challenging that part of the
law
he's afraid that the law will Outlaw
discussions of systemic racism which he
says is part of family's institutional
history
the state created the law school in 1949
to accommodate two black law students
who applied to the racially segregated
University of Florida
in 1966 the state forced it to seize
admitting new students until then
Florida Governor Jeb Bush signed a law
to reopen it in 2000 Purnell worries
that if instructors were to characterize
that history as systemically racist
they'd run afoul of the Law's
restrictions around teaching the concept
I have no way of knowing that my passion
for teaching students about history
about change about the ability to bring
about change I have no way of knowing
that that isn't offensive to these
subjective judges of what is endorsing
what is not endorsing what is promoting
what is not not promoting so I do now
live with the idea that at any moment
the state can come and take negative
action against me because of my thought
let's say that there was a blue state
that did kind of the opposite of this
and they said we're going to ban a
professor who has a different Viewpoint
and thinks critical race theory is wrong
and that we should be talking about
color blindness as a legitimate concept
and things like this anytime you put
State and band together danger all right
why does the state ban any thought
if we are in a free society
that exists and develops based on free
exchange of ideas
so uh Professor Purnell there is taking
a very principled stance he is in he
believes in uh systemic racism and
thinks critical race theory is an
important uh academic concept but he
does not would not be it sounds like he
would not be in favor of a law like the
California law that forces professors to
Embrace or promulgate these Concepts I I
guess my question this could be the last
question for you Bill because I know you
have to leave so feel free to jump off
whenever you need to after this but do
you feel the same way in the reverse
Direction
um that
professors who do believe in many of
these Concepts we've gone through in the
Dei framework should be free to teach
those in the classroom
provided that their students are free to
disagree and not be graded negatively
um I would would support that as long as
it goes both ways
but frequently that is not the case
you know I support Professor Cornell's
freedom of speech in the classroom to
teach the material as he sees fit but I
also support
and would make sure that this is brought
up in that discussion that his students
have the right to disagree with him and
lay out their case and that's the whole
whole point of higher education anyway
is that is the free exchange of ideas
May the best idea win and sometimes even
though we're right and we're arguing
or a particular position that is is
right our arguments may be weak and we
lose that particular argument so you go
back you regroup you redevelop and come
back again
and that's that's how it was when I went
through college and that's how it should
be
the idea of May the best idea win I
think is so important and many of the
DIA cheerleaders are in a sense uh
betraying a sense of like their own
insecurities
um if you're attempting to so rigidly
impose this Orthodoxy uh and mandating
it from on high at least to me that
indicates a certain sense of like oh
maybe they're not so confident that
these ideas would win in the marketplace
um because they're not choosing to use
those sort of like classically liberal
means of duking it out it is instead a
different approach being tried right now
and that really raises my hackles at
least where I sort of am like wait a
second you know is there an insecurity
being communicated there are they
actually confident that these ideas
would win
yeah and you know uh Liz when I raised
that that phrase the marketplace of
ideas with Chris Ruffo in a previous
live stream that we had he disagreed
that we even have a Marketplace of ideas
in higher education uh we're gonna drop
links to all this media in the
description so uh you know you if you're
interested in this conversation you
might want to check out that full stream
with rufo but I want to play uh a clip
of what rufos our counter argument was
in that that debates or discussion with
with me and Nick Gillespie and then get
you to react to the argument that he's
making in favor of the stock woke act
Jesse because he was one of the
intellectual Architects behind it
this has argued that it does have a say
over what's taught at taxpayer
subsidized schools teaching kids that's
not the right uh clip uh let's see
thank you
uh I I don't uh like you I guess I don't
support abolishing them but when they're
off track when they're not supporting
those values when they're not pursuing
those as the tell-offs or the highest
principle of the University it's up to
the voters to Institute reforms and what
we have is a situation where there is
not uh there's a kind of uh uh a a a a
kind of written idea of academic freedom
but the actual on the ground facts I've
talked to a lot of professors in the UF
system uh that are conservative that say
I can't express my opinion I can't do
the research I want if I say that I'm
conservative I won't get tenure
um uh my ideas are suppressed I'm forced
to go through these diversity trainings
this is a problem for people within the
the system it's also a problem for the
public to say hey wait a minute
if you're a public if you're
professoriate if you're faculty because
of the hiring and because of the funding
and because of the selection process is
now in many public universities 20 30 40
to 1 depended on the Departments between
progressives or liberals and
conservatives you have a massive
imbalance in faculty you have an
Administration that has adopted Dei as
the highest principle of the universe
enforcing professors to to bow down to
left-wing diversity ideology they're
forcing professors to sign diversity
statements okay they're forcing
professors to be hired on the basis of
their commitment to these ideologies you
have a huge problem and yes what I'm
hearing is that well you can't do
anything about it because you know
government bad
how do you reply to that argument rufos
making Jesse which is that these are
public institutions and therefore we the
government
through the legislative process the
democratically elected legislator they
should be able to
shape the standards of what is allowed
to be taught on a college campus
uh well first I just say to
think that
uh in the answer to an insufficient
Marketplace of ideas is to censor part
of the marketplace
is a very odd response uh
as for
the taxpayer-funded nature of
universities uh
taxpayers fund user universities because
they are knowledge generating machines
and they generate that knowledge by
bringing together a lot of people a lot
of ideas to kind of duke it out and
hopefully from that process
we can discover some sort of Truth gain
some sort of knowledge uh historically
that has worked actually quite well in
the United States and that's why we fund
universities uh
taxpayer funding does not mean that
taxpayers get to tell every government
employee what they can and can't say
that's never how it's worked and it's
not how it works when it comes to
universities
the interest of taxpayers and of the
government in a university is both the
knowledge generating and the education
of adult college students again we want
to expose them to a variety of ideas and
that is very very different from say uh
what you see in the K-12 environment
where your
where the Public's interest is more
inculcating Community Values in young
children
in college you want to bring together
all sorts of ideas and expose students
to all of them
and yeah you know Liz talked earlier a
little bit about the I think she said
tightrope that you are walking at fire
where you are willing to take on both of
these cases it's vanishingly rare that I
mean I feel like it's maybe uh us and
and fire at this point that that are
willing to do that civil liberties
oriented organization that I've heard so
much about but I'm not sure
there used to be another one I read
Glasser one that was on all sides but
but I mean maybe that maybe that plays
into why fire has Rebrand you know you
started as the foundation for individual
rights in education and now uh you have
expanded that beyond the educational
sphere I mean is there any insight that
you can give us there as to you know why
has fire uh expanded its Mission
um is it because of that that lack of
people willing to to walk that tightrope
I think
um there was definitely a need for
an organization to come out and
be willing to defend Free Speech just
because it's free speech and not on the
grounds of the
uh correctness of the opinion being
given uh and I know that fire first
before it
ever wanted to expand it wanted to make
sure that it was doing everything it
could in the higher education space and
so it grew enough to kind of
um
perfect its craft there and then it
became time where
um
they could jump into
The Wider uh community and it also uh
happened to coincide with
um a lot of the negative trends that
we've seen in higher education as
students graduate are
kind of coming out into the broader
world and uh it's a good time for fire
to expand and counter that outside of
the University system as well
yeah this is also interesting to me
because I feel like I um got a very
early Taste of this I entered College in
2014 and left College in 2016 but it was
interesting because I think so many
people when attempting to trace
um this sort of second wave of political
correctness on campus obviously we had
the wave in the 90s which I know Greg
Lucian off of fire has actually written
about
um wonderfully for a reason uh for our
print magazine of like hey actually this
wave of political correctness on campus
this isn't really the first time this
has happened this has been a little bit
of a cyclical thing throughout
um you know recent American history but
I do think that this most recent wave is
really traced back to starting around
Ferguson Missouri 2014
um that whole thing and and it was
really interesting to arrive on campus
write us so much of this was bubbling up
um but then I see so much of my cohort I
mean I got the hell out of college and
early because in part because of this
and so much of my cohort it's been so
interesting watching them then go into
you know major newsrooms and other
different Industries and it's
fascinating how these ideas that I think
were either you know inculcated at the
University level or not pushed back on
sufficiently at the University level you
know Circa 2015 2016 2017 have really
now flowered into something else and
taken root in all kinds of other
Industries I reported a piece for our
friend Mike Solana of pirate wires a few
maybe a year and a half ago that talked
a little bit about uh the DI efforts at
tech companies and the sort of like dihr
convergence and how for many Tech
employees
um you know it's it's many of the same
objections that we're launching here
um and that Professor blinken has has
commented on here where it's a little
bit of like well wait a second doesn't
this distract from the actual thing we
were hired to do doesn't this distract
um you know in the professor's case from
educating students from teaching them
chemistry or in the tech employee case
uh from sales goals uh or you know
creating the best possible software to
solve their customers so I think there's
there's something that people are sort
of slowly coming around to which is like
a lot of these things distract people
who actually want to
um roll up their sleeves and get hard
work done and there's also a certain
hollowness that I think people are sort
of slowly becoming wise to
um and you know at the same time this
also then breeds an entire industry of
what I view as grifters like the Chris
ruffos of the world who are really
converting a lot of this um craziness
into their own sort of culture war and
mandating another form of viewpoint
homogeneity which I'm not super keen on
so you know all props to fire for
fighting the good fight and for the
professors uh who are willing to stick
their necks out and possibly take an
unpopular position uh in pursuit of more
academic freedom uh thank you guys so
much for talking to us
yeah and uh the the issue with the the
mandating aspect that's the key word uh
Liz that you mentioned is that you know
we can sit here and have our criticisms
of these Concepts and I think they're
warranted and you know even when they're
not mandated I think there's a lot of uh
self-destructive
ideas that we've gone over today that
that should be vigorously criticized but
it is a the the reason we Advocate on
Marketplace of ideas is because this
stuff is really complicated and reducing
it to its you know woke versus non-woke
and this all has this all is Gospel or
this all is garbage it doesn't really
make sense it has to kind of play out in
a messy social process and and the less
we have
uh you know governments or uh Community
College state connected Community
College review boards uh trying to
impose their vision of the social good
the more we can actually I think uh
progress and get to an actual social
good I want to just uh since bill is uh
here I wouldn't want to he's still here
I want to just get his your any final
thoughts that you have
um maybe about the concept of academic
freedom and and why um that you chose to
put yourself out there as one of the
faces of this lawsuit yeah
well first I kind of want to say that
um there really isn't a free exchange of
ideas on your typical college campus
anymore at all
Christian conservatives who are pro-life
you're not going to get tenure you're
not even going to get hired
um so that that is just the reality of
the situation
now uh why did I join this lawsuit well
first of all I'm concerned about my own
job
uh I'm I either I have the choice of
either
going along with something that I
believe to be completely untrue so then
in effect I lie
and that's one choice and the other
choice is to be honest
and say I believe in treating students
the same regardless of their skin color
and then I run the risk of losing my job
and somebody has to stand up and do
something
and part of it is my own trying to
preserve my job but also is
um to try to for Generations that are
coming behind me because I'm not that
far from retirement that they'll have
the right to teach higher ed or teach
really anywhere in the way that's
appropriate for the subject matter and I
actually did have a faculty member thank
me that
um
you know for on behalf of of his
children who may want to be professors
someday and trying to
protect their future rights and that's
ultimately what this takes is it just
takes
somebody who's going to stand up and say
no this isn't right and fire you know
joined with us and took our case
and here we are
and Jesse what is the status of the case
what should people who want to follow it
look out for next
uh
uh recently filed our motion for
preliminary injunction which requests
that the court uh essentially put a halt
to enforcement of the regulation while
litigation is ongoing and we will have a
hearing on that in about a
probably about a month uh and that is a
good
um
that decision that we get on the motion
for preliminary injunction is kind of a
good
precursor of how the entire case will go
because it's the
um it is only issued if the judge
believes that you are likely going to
succeed on the merits down the road so
that would be the first thing to uh
watch for is uh we are going to argue
that in about a month and uh we're
hopeful that we'll be successful
okay well we will watch and wait and I
want to reiterate what Liz was saying
and thank you both for what you're doing
and for giving your time to us today to
share what's going on with the case uh
Liz thank you for joining uh thanks to
everyone who tuned in we'll be back next
week next Thursday at 1pm see you then